I grew up in the parallel universe that
used the e I remember it was the
bernstein bear
[Music]
so if there's really good memory and
there's really bad memory I would say
I'm in the middle long-term memory great
short-term memory my memories okay but
like going downhill as I get older so I
feel like I have a pretty good memory
oh is it Sex in the City or Sex and the
City that's the question I have gone on
sex with city vendors before Sex in the
City baby
no is it not am I wrong
incorrect you have sex in the city
it's mirror mirror on the wall who's the
fairest of them all isn't it mirror
mirror magic fairy no no it's not you're
lying it's a beautiful day in the
neighborhood this neighborhood which
neighborhood a beautiful day in this he
does not sing it like that see this is
also bad songwriting if it's this is it
I don't know that doesn't sound right
someone should have given him a no blink
I am your father dad and now I know it's
not gonna do whatever's obvious is it
Luke guessing it's this this is Jim that
is this silly I'm gonna go home me cry
now
Kazaam chips dablam I don't know of any
movie featuring Sinbad as a genie Shazam
there was no movie
what there's a movie called Shazam who
ever look at that real quick possible
I've seen the movie Shazam he's a genie
in it
the Berenstein bears alright well no I'm
good
no it's not Berenstain that says
Berenstain I don't know who's lobbying
for big a but I'm just gonna say it's
some nonsense and those bears deserve
better I hate life everything is put a
lie I refuse to change my mind I think
those signs are from an alternate
universe I don't think it's implausible
to assume that there's billions of
alternate timelines all occurring at
once on different planes of existence I
mean you know there's no movie called
Shazam apparently so I guess anything's
possible
I'd like to think that I'm from the
parallel universe a lot of dogs lots of
color blue weird people I'm fine with
that
Kazaam is real chisaem is real